All right. Good people or the
Internet, sorry for the delay, right.
They're joining me today is a professor
of marketing at Concordia University,
an author and a behavioral scientist.
But most importantly,
I believe officially right now the most
returning guests to the Rubin report.
Dr Gad said,
welcome to the Rubin report.
So kind of retaught me again to put
up with me yet again. All right,
well I thought we do this just one
more time. Let's just finish this.
You know what I mean?
This every couple of months.
It's been 16 months since my last
appearance. It's been 16 months,
I think it was in August, 2017 so it's
been awhile. Well, it's sort of fitting.
So this is actually my
last taping of the year.
We've taped where you have a couple more
shows coming out that we taped earlier
this week because of my travel schedule.
But I thought it's kind of fitting that
you're in my last show of 2018 because
you were the first of the first.
You did our first test show or a
TV in August of 2015 that's right.
So over three years ago,
about three and a half years ago.
That feels like freaking lifetime.
Look at you now. You're like,
are you the most famous person
in the world? Now? Third
Most Lady Gaga, Pewdie Pie.
Pretty Pioneer. And there you go. But
it does seem like a lifetime ago. And I,
more than anything else,
I want to cover a ton of new ground today.
That's what I want to do.
Got a lot of new ground right here.
And I know you're working on all sorts
of things and you got a new book coming
and everything else.
But first I thought because you also are
on Patrion and this happens to be the
topic that everyone's talking
about at the moment. Uh,
I want to just talk a little bit
about censorship and platforming and D
platforming and the rest of it.
Um,
do you want to lay out quickly what
happened to Sargon or do you want me to do
it? Uh, no, you go ahead and do it. So,
just very briefly for people that don't
know a Sargon of Akkad who is a popular
Youtuber,
he was one of the first sort of from the
classical liberal space when I was kind
of waking up to what was going on with uh,
with the left related to free
speech and sort of the SJW hysteria.
Everyone said you gotta
talk to Sargon of a cod.
I didn't even know if it was a real
person or who the hell this guy was. Um,
he was booted off Patrion
a couple of days ago, uh,
with no recourse with no warning because
10 months ago in February on another
channel,
not his own channel,
that's very tiny youtube channel with
4,000 subscribers on an audio interview
show with the Non English native speaker,
which I only mentioned
because the conversation was
a little stilted because of
the language.
He said the n word and he said
it not to be racially pejorative,
but he said it because he was sort of
using the language of the alt right
against themselves.
Patriot heard him say this,
they don't think about or look
into context and they booed him.
And this is actually a pretty
big thing in our space.
I usually don't like talking to this much
at the beginning of a show and I hand
it to you.
What do you make of what's going on with
platform and [inaudible] platform and
we are both on Patrion et cetera.
Well, I'll just say that, uh,
I mean I was heavily hit but
my pi of the big Patrion yeah,
my slice of the pie is very small.
I had maybe 600 patrons and I think I
checked last maybe a day and a half ago
and I had lost more than a hundred
out of 600 or so. That's a lie.
So that's a lie. It's not a lot of money
that I'm making under the platform,
but it still hurts. Uh, I
really think that it stems from,
and I think it might be one of the
things that you had on the list for us to
talk about. You know, oftentimes people
pit these binaries against one another.
You're either thinking person or in
multiple person, you either, uh, you know,
it's either rational or emotional.
I think one of the things
that you're writing about,
I'm writing about this in the book,
right?
Because I want to explain this very quick
trigger of our treasure arises in many
contexts in universities and companies
and when they deep platform people,
so I think people use these fast and
frugal you eristics oftentimes is uris
sticks work well.
But on other other cases where you miss
apply an emotional reaction in a context
where it would require a
bit more cognitive effort,
this is where you get
some of these problems.
So can you give me an example of first,
when does a heuristic that just
is like the immediate reaction?
If I'm walking down,
uh,
taking a shortcut to go home and I
see three young men that look quite
suspicious, uh, my heart starts
racing, I start maybe sweating a bit,
uh,
my blood pressure goes up.
So I'm getting a emotional reaction that's
physiological based precisely because
it makes sense at that moment for
this autonomic reaction to take place.
If I'm trying to solve a calculus
problem than calling all of my emotional
system into action might
not be the right thing.
So the argument is that it's not that we
are either rational or emotional being,
it's that you should trigger,
forgive the term. Yeah,
he should activate the correct
system at the appropriate time.
And I think what happens with a lot of
these social justice warrior types is
that they're very much driven by the
emotional system in the wrong context.
And that's what you get the kinds of
situations like with Sargon. Yeah.
So to live life as a functioning human,
you need a little push and pull on that.
Right? Right, exactly.
You need the emotive stuff and
then you need the cognitive stuff.
Why do you think this is
happening at these platforms?
Why do you think they are bowing?
I mean,
they're really just bowing
to the mob every time.
And the reason I'm so concerned about it
is not only just because of how I feel
about free speech, but
we're watching. I mean,
we're just in slow motion watching
those lines. They're coming both ways,
but mostly it's coming. Let's say from
the SJW left, so I'll use this hand.
It's moving really fast this way,
where it's going to be that everybody
is going to be on the outs because if a
guy like are,
who as far as I can tell is just an
old school liberal and you know he's a
provocateur. I'm going
to show twice. Yeah.
And he never said anything
that struck me as unreasonable.
He seems like a very reasonable, fair guy.
Yeah. And look, he's a bit of a troll.
He's a bit bit of a provocateur,
all of those things.
But the point is that if a guy like Carl,
Carl Benjamin, that's his real name,
if he can't be on a platform,
then half the people that we
know and maybe that includes us,
can't be on these platforms.
So what do you think is happening
at the high levels of that?
Of what I mean it's a
combination of many things.
I think one of the things is that
this, this the, the I call it,
or in my Canadian Senate in 2017
when I went to talk about bill,
she's 16 lovely boat tonight.
Thank you very much. Oh, I
thank you for remembering.
Uh, I talked about the, I'm a victim,
therefore I am ethos, right? Uh,
it used to be out. I think
therefore I am now is I'm a victim.
So to, to, to stay true
to a victimology ethos,
you have to be outraged.
You have to be indignant,
you have to self flagellate at
the altar of progressivism and,
and people are cognitive misers. In
other words, they're cognitively lazy.
And now I've got this autonomic system
that where I can draw on my emotional
indignation to navigate through the world.
Well,
for the social justice warrior types,
it's easy to fall prey to the hyper
activation of the emotional system.
Right? As you said, it's not
that we are this or that. And I,
I think I emailed you yesterday,
one of the concepts that I'm developing
in my book is this idea of what I call
epistemological.
They Kowtow mania at diff,
seeing the world as sort
of opposing binary's.
We are rational and we are emotional.
They are very clear evolutionary reasons
why we've evolved the capacity to think,
but also very clear evolutionary
reasons why anger and envy and shot than
farther and compassion have also evolved.
So we're both just triggered the
right system at the right time.
So do you think part of it is just
that the speed of the Internet,
the fact that you can be on Twitter so
quickly releasing this stuff that you can
learn more faster now?
Right?
You can listen to podcasts in double
speed and that you can take in so much
inflammation and shoot out so much
information that that maybe is triggering
your word, some of the, the
hyperactive emotional stuff. Yeah,
I mean as opposed to using a
more rational, logical, although,
or you're not succumbing to that.
Right? So, so what's wrong with me?
So it is really an interaction perhaps of
the environment that you're describing,
but it has to be the right personality.
Who succumbs to that hyper
active emotional system.
You're not succumbing to it.
I'm not succumbing to it.
And so I'd like for people to develop if,
I don't know if this is the right term
or a good term, but at mental hygiene,
right? In the same way that
we develop personal hygiene.
I mean stop for a minute,
think about it that, what's the
context under which Sargon you know,
uttered that particular world word and
now that there is so much information
that suggests that there was a context,
why can't you reverse it?
Why can't you set it correctly? Well, it's
because it's very, for people to admit,
Mia Culpa,
I was wrong.
And so then they anchor in their position
and nothing's going to move them from
them. It's very bad business. You know,
it's interesting because
I do find there are times,
especially lately I've
really been trying to,
not that I was ever like over the
top hostile to people on Twitter,
but I used to go in and attack people
more and or, or not attack people,
but usually attack ideas.
But now I do find a lot of times I
write a draft and I kind of just take a
breath and I'm like,
you know what?
Maybe just let this go because I sense
there's a growing feeling and maybe it's
only online.
I hope it's only online that people
really want to burn everything down. Yeah.
Do you sense that, I mean, as
someone that studies behavior,
you studied behavior that, that
people who live in the West, you know,
I live in the United States,
you wouldn't kind of,
we live in two of the freest
countries in the history of the world.
You can wake up if you live in America
or Canada and basically do what ever you
want. It doesn't mean you're
going to be successful at it,
but you can try at least.
And yet there is this growing feeling
that we got to just tear this whole thing
down. Yeah. It's unbelievable.
I mean, one of the, the, the,
the things that people tell me when
they meet me in person, as I said, well,
you know, I've seen you brawl with people
on Twitter and yet in the rest of your
interactions, you seem to be so
lovely and jovial and friendly.
While the reality is that Twitter brings
out the worst in all of us right? It,
I analogize it,
it's akin to two guys brawling
in an alley. Right? But they,
you oftentimes,
those who criticize you will,
will commit what's called the
fundamental attribution error,
the fundamental attribution error. If I
may just stay society, it's where you,
you missed the here to teach
me [inaudible] kind of APP.
You miss attribute something
dispositionally to the
person when it should have
been attributed to the situation.
Right? So when I am brawling,
usually with a smile on my
face with someone on Twitter,
it's the situation that's at hand
that's causing me to be combative.
That's not my disposition.
When I,
when I tuck my children
to bed and I kissed him,
I don't troll them and call them
customer at all. Right? But,
but somehow people attribute that to you.
Dispositionally you're a combative person,
then they meet you and say, my God,
you're so warm and smiley and so on.
Uh,
so I think there are all sorts of really
interesting psychological processes
that are causing us to behave in ways
on Twitter that otherwise we wouldn't
behave that way.
It would be interesting.
I don't know if you know
anything about this specifically,
but just because of the way you've
studied behavior to show that when other
technologies came out over
the course of human history,
if they so quickly change the
way we behave with each other,
so say when the printing press came out
and now more people that information did
that immediately mean that people are
yelling at each other more or something
like that. I wonder if there is some, I
don't know about that, but what I can say.
Do you know what is the one industry
that is always at the cutting edge of
technology? Yes. My friend.
It's porn. Very good.
Look at nights I saw, I'm
looking at exact says, you know,
we're not going to do this. It's
unbelievable. Guys are moving to tape.
I'm going to do this on film. And yeah,
but so what's the purpose there? Well,
it's just that they're always trying
to find the new ways to deliver that
consumer story experience to
you and therefore they are at,
they're not just creating pornography,
which is not very difficult to explain
from an evolutionary perspective.
They are really at the,
at the front of finding new technologies
to deliver these systems. So,
which speaks to another point
that I was going to talk about.
Oftentimes I get emails from people.
Why did you choose to apply, you know,
all your biological, uh, knowledge, your
psychological knowledge to marketing?
And the answer to that for me is that
marketing and consumer behavior is the
perfect place to study human nature.
Short of my breathing,
the thing that I do most is consume,
but I don't just consume Coca Cola
and Starbucks. I consume friendships,
we consume ideas, we consume
religious narratives. We,
so everything is conservatory.
So the reason why I love marketing so
much because people think of the term
marketing in a colloquial sense. You're
trying to market the next HIP party,
right? So they think I sit
there and I design, uh, Ma, uh,
restaurant menus as my job.
Well, if that was true,
you probably have a lot more money.
If you had mastered that,
what the Hell would you be teaching
for? Exactly? Marketing is really,
so some marketers or marketing professors
are anthropologists who study the,
the,
the ethnography of consumption.
Others are psychologists who study the
psychological basis of consumption.
Others are applied mathematicians on
the same way that a climatologist uses
mathematical models to study climate
systems, applied mathematicians,
study marketing systems.
So people have to understand that there's
a different term that's being used.
When you think about marketing as a
colloquial term versus marketing as a
scientific discipline.
Marketing as a scientific discipline
is simply the application of cognitive
disciplines for the study of
the marketing realm. Okay,
so if we want to bring
this back then to the,
to the first question about the
platforming, as a behavioral scientist,
perhaps we're not doing something right
as consumers of of these platforms were
really the product,
but as the users of these platforms,
is there a behavioral modification we
should be doing to get these companies to
behave differently towards us?
I think as long as there are no direct
consequences to their behaviors.
I mean really when, when people,
boycotts Patriot, I mean,
yes they're sending a message to patron,
but the most immediate effect that
is felt as by you and me. Right?
And so I did this live stream last night
and I said, and this is completely true,
that I've lost about 500 some
odd patrons we've lost about,
I think it's around 5,000
bucks a month already.
But as I'm watching the number drop,
I honestly truly yet I'm inspired in
a way like, because it's like, oh,
people are standing up for
themselves. So it's like, and yeah,
and a lot of them were finding me on
my website now and doing it there.
So it's not like I'm taking
a complete financial hit,
but people are messaging me and saying
I'm not going to take it anymore.
And for that I'm like,
so it's weird.
I'm like kind of inspired on one hand and
then my business is this. Dave is like,
Oh shit. But I have to agree
with you because one of the,
one of the sort of the signature
things that I sign off with,
oftentimes as I tell people don't sit
idly. You have a voice, get engaged.
And so it's difficult to then get upset
at people for getting engaged simply
because you take a financial hit.
Right? Right. So in the bigger picture,
I agree with you, I understand their
frustration and I hope that Jack Conti is,
is watching this.
What do you make of the behavior of people
that live in free societies that are
afraid to actually be free?
Because you know,
I just traveled the world all year with
Jordan and the amount of people that I
met,
especially in the Scandinavian countries,
but all over the world
and including American,
we did probably 15 stops in Canada.
People that live in freezes identities
that actually are afraid to speak.
It drives me absolutely crazy.
I respect jihadists more than I respect
people in free societies who refuse to
speak because the jihadis at
least are really committed.
They wake up every morning
and they have a goal.
It's a goal that you and I might
find it to be x, x, a credible,
but they are committed. Those who sit
quietly while you know the, the ugly,
the tsunami of lunacy is coming upon us.
Uh,
I have nothing but the stain for
them and it really isn't. She is.
So what is that behaviorally?
What is that?
Is that just a function of our excess
in the West? We've done it right.
Basically, we're basically free. We
got playstation, we got Coca Cola,
we got Nike, and we've been
lulled into nothing. Then I
think it's many things. Uh,
number one,
I truly believe that those who come from
societies that weren't free Ion Hirsi
Ali, myself, uh,
we really do understand what magical
reality the west is and the whole totality
of societies that have ever existed in
the compendium of societies in the world.
We're nothing but a small bleep.
We've really done something right.
I think most Westerners don't
know that there is, I mean,
maybe sort of the abstract,
they know that there are some
really bad places out there,
but they take things for granted
there. But, um, uh, Regan had said,
I'm going to paraphrase, I don't
remember the exact quote. You know,
every single generation you have to be
standing at the gate defending freedoms
because every generation's,
there's going to be intrusions of some
really in the various characters trying
to take away those freedoms. And so
maybe in your book, maybe in mind,
we have to find ways to come
up with prescriptions to
get the silent majority of
speak. Do you know what the
secret is to get them to speak?
I don't know what the secret is other
than you've got to keep telling them that.
That's the answer like there,
because that's the question I probably
get more at any Q and a that I do than
anything else is I want to get involved,
but I don't know what to do.
And it's like you don't have to
make a youtube channel tomorrow.
Although I tell people, get on all of
these platforms and do those things.
But just in your own life, don't be
afraid of having these conversations.
If you're truly afraid that you're going
to say I'm for a low taxes and your
cousin's going to tell
you you're a racist,
that's not going to magically get better.
You know what I mean?
It's gonna actually,
it'll magically get worse.
So I think it's just on you
person watching this now to do it.
Uh,
earlier today I was at Bible Island and
Newport beach with my family and we ran
into an older gentleman, I think he's
80 years old. We had seen him around,
we were often in California and we love
the stock. He's got a Shetland shepherds.
So we stopped to pet the dog and we
ended up talking at one point, you know,
so I guess he's finding
out what I do and so on.
And he tells me with a lot of hesitation
as if there's going to be this great
repercussion on him. He admits to
me this very, very dark, a secret.
He's a Trump supporter. And I said, Oh,
why do you say that with
such hesitation when I,
so here's an 80 year old gentlemen,
we'll live supposedly in the most free
society sitting on a Free Street in
Newport beach.
Yet he felt sufficiently tepid about
simply saying that he supports the current
sitting US president that captures it all.
That that's it.
I mean, to be free and to be, well
you're your own hostage at some level.
The other thing I that I find
very interesting is that,
so I was speaking actually with
Jordan and a few others at an event.
This was the event in 2017 where we were
going to speak about the stifling of
free speech on university campuses
that will shut down, shut down.
And then there was the rescheduled.
Yeah. So in the Q and a, uh,
someone asks who, who is of each of
the people who were in the panel,
who is your, uh, sort of freedom
hero? And my answer was, well,
it's all the people who do what we do,
but they do it in the Middle East, right.
Where the repercussions on them as they
might be taken in the middle of the
night and you'll never
hear from them again.
Now what upsets me is that if
you ask people in the West,
as you were saying earlier than that,
who are too afraid to speak well,
what are you afraid of? It's
unbelievable. The banality of their fears.
Well, I'm so if they're a professor,
well I'm afraid that might,
the chair of my department might
give me my core slowed on Tuesdays,
but he knows that on Tuesdays
my son has soccer practice.
That's what you're basing the whole
edifice of your defense of freedom on the
fact that he might screw
around with your teaching. So,
so there is a misalignment
between what people fear. I mean,
I get a million death threats. That's,
that's real, right? Yeah. I use,
I had last semester by though and that
last one I started in fall 2017 I had to
be escorted on my
university with security.
I had to file a police report
with the Montreal police.
I mean that's a lot worse than you.
They didn't give me the right schedule
to teach on Tuesday because my,
but that's the banality of their fears.
Their unfounded, just speak up. Yeah.
I always ask a lot of my
more courageous guests this.
But what do you think it is about you?
Do you think it's just because of what
happened to you in Lebanon growing up?
I mean, it is, if people
don't know the story,
they absolutely should check out our
other interviews. Cause your, your,
your life story is incredible. Do
you want me to summarize it? Yeah.
If you want to do that. I mean we're,
we're Lebanese Jews who lived in Lebanon.
I mean all my parents might,
siblings are much older than me and
myself were all born in Lebanon.
We were part of the last group of
Lebanese Jews who were still in Lebanon.
The civil war broke out into the mid
seven in the mid seventies where it was no
longer possible to be Jewish in Lebanon.
And so we have to leave, you know, very,
very quickly. Uh, so in my
personal history of course,
uh, is as part of the
reasons why I do, I do.
But I really think it's the unique random
combination of genes that makes who
got side is, which is, I'm genuinely,
and I say this without any hyperbole,
I'm genuinely offended by bs.
Yeah.
So sometimes my wife will see me,
I have my head in my hand and I'm like,
oh my God, what did somebody write? And
it will be something that I just read. Uh,
there is a retreat in Costa Rica
where whites are not allowed. Yeah.
This was like the hot thing that
vice was tweeting it. Exactly. Yeah.
And then I watched it. I went
absolutely berserk. I said,
how could it be that the same society
that created Martin Luther King,
this is not 4,000 years ago. This is
within, well not maybe you being alive,
but I was maybe two, three
years old. Yeah. This,
the same society that created
a Martin Luther King, 40,
50 years later is the same
society that rejoices, right.
Vice news was not saying,
look at these idiots.
There's how progressive
it is that there is a,
a American woman who has started to
retreat where whites are not allowed,
where they take breaks from white
people. Well, just look at my toe now.
It upsets me now possibly because I also
come from the society where I come from,
where I know what real hatred is.
There is no such hatred in the u s stop
pretending that there is such a thing.
Yeah,
well we're looking for it all the time.
We're looking at if you want to find
racism everywhere and bigotry everywhere,
guess what, you will find it. And if you
don't, you'll just make it up. So exactly.
What's it been like for you?
So you just mentioned having to
be escorted off campus. So in the,
in the couple times that we've done this,
obviously your public profile has grown
and you're extremely outspoken. Um,
what's it been like just on
campus in general? Holly Eggs?
I'm guessing you probably
get a lot of silence,
support and probably not a lot
of public support. I mean it's,
it's the same old story with everybody.
That's the,
that's the either depressing or at some
level inspiring part of this that maybe
there are many more of us,
which would be inspiring.
But the depressing is it's
like you're just a man. Yeah.
You're just one guy doing what you think
is right. How you have about four hours.
So let me summarize a few of the things
that have happened over the past year.
Yeah. Uh, so my university, I,
I'm not saying this not to be diplomatic,
but there are many,
many great things about my university.
They truly have given me an environment
to flourish. They don't get in my way.
They've never come and said,
don't say this and don't say that.
But I think my public profile now is
scaring them. So I know for a fact,
for example, that the media
department at my university,
I used to be their hero every five
seconds they used to call me. I mean,
I won the president's award,
the president of the university's
award for the guy who gets the most
international media coverage. That
was in 2015. Well from 2015 to now,
my profile has grown,
grown about 13th trillion times.
So if I want it in 2015 you would
think that I'm certainly up there.
I've completely become invisible to the
university so they don't actively come
and stop me from saying something,
but it's as if they want to hold that I
go away and I've spoken to a few senior
administrators and it's kind of relates
back to what we talked about earlier,
this kind of emotional mechanism.
Some of them are upset at the fact that
I called someone schmuck on Twitter.
So all of Lord never called anybody ish.
Exactly. And I've actually had some odds,
I'll tell you another quick story.
There was a gentleman with whom I was
communicating on Twitter around them
person,
I have no idea who this person is.
And at one point I called them
a degenerate retarded schmuck.
Okay. Twitter banned me. I found
out it's because I used the r word.
I get a call from a university,
a human resources person after hours to
to discuss the fact that a complaint had
been filed against me.
Now I was thinking, oh,
this must be in the context of my
job as a professor in the university.
And there's absolutely
no way that they could,
anybody could have any reproach against
me because I, I conduct myself in a very,
very austere, you know,
professional, professorial
manner. There's no, no, no, it's,
they were referring to that interaction
with a random person on Twitter to which
I answered,
I told the person who I was speaking to,
so let me just make sure that I get
this straight so that when I repeated on
high profile platforms,
I don't get it wrong.
You think that it is within the purview
of the university to contact a professor
and determine what he or she can or can't
say using which tone on Twitter when
they're engaging another
person as a private citizen.
So if I were to hear you
speaking to your daughter,
coming out of the pharmacy in a tone
that I decided that I didn't approve of,
can I report you to the university?
The conversation ended
very quickly after that.
So the fact that the
universities are even in Bolden,
that they have the reflex to feel that
it is okay for them to be questioning
which word you use on
Twitter is a problem.
And the fact that you fought back boldly
probably made them scatter very quick
because they don't expect
anyone to [inaudible]. Right.
So why do you think universities have a
different responsibility when it comes
to speech? So of course in the United
States where we have the first amendment,
which is about the government
coming for your speech,
I think is being now confused with
generally your right to free speech.
Anyone can say whatever they want with
the very limited exceptions of fire in a
crowded theater, et Cetera,
et cetera. Um, but you know,
something like Marc Lamont
Hill a couple of weeks ago,
he gave that that
insanely over the top and,
and truly racist to the Cedar River,
to the sea power should be
free from the rivers. He,
that is literally what Hamas says.
I mean, it is a call for genocide.
Everyone knows what it is now. In
my view, the school, Temple and CNN,
his network can do whatever they want.
They can associate or not associate,
but I know there's a little bit
of a, an egg. And I say that as a,
as a free speech guy,
it's like he can say what he wants,
the school can associate
with who they want.
I don't want the government forcing
him to stay or forcing him to go.
But that to me is what freedom is.
It's the messy exchange of freedom.
But do you think in a case like that,
do you think universities have an extra
responsibility to protect free speech
when it's speech that they
don't, uh, agree with? Uh,
so the way I would answer it,
I'll, and I'll, although I'm
very conflicted about it,
I don't think that temple should find,
I say this as a Jewish person who has
a lot of family in Israel. I don't,
despite the fact that I don't
agree with what he said,
and he is aping the exact slogan of Hamas,
I don't think that they should fire him.
I think the only thing that should make
you bet should a fireable offense is
that within your role as a
professor in the university,
if you do things that violate the
dictums of your job as a professor.
Yeah. Short of that, I'm a
free speech absolutist. See,
that's the irony of where we're
at with the platforms too.
Because you could also argue,
well wait a minute, so are gone,
did something off platform and he's
getting banned. You know, they said,
they said it's only if you
do it on platform. Now he
did something off platform.
So that's why all of these things
are so confusing and intertwined.
Can I share one other story?
Not Mine,
although I want to maybe
mention one other example.
I'll mention my story first and
then I'll mention another guy. Uh,
another thing that struck,
cause you're asking what's happening
on universities and in my personal
experience,
so now the equity and diversity stuff
is spreading like wildfire across all
institutions in Canada because we have,
you know,
Justin Trudeau who's really
pushing this everywhere, right?
And so they're not happy.
Well, I can't say they,
but I did about 15 shows this year
in Canada and they're not on time.
I mentioned Trudeau people would move.
Do you know how many,
he was the punchline of all my
jokes and it was that, that,
that a Trudeau and everyone goes nuts.
Do you know how many people
have written to me now saying,
I wish we would have hated your
warnings about Trudeau in the past?
So yes, Stephen Harper is looking
pretty good these days. Although I,
my prediction, regrettably,
I think he'll win again,
but because there isn't anybody who is,
uh,
oh and beat him on the charisma factor,
I think the current guy is not going to
do it. I've seen Bernay coming in. Do you?
Okay, very nice. Uh, but so, so
the equity and diversity stuff, uh,
the Canadian government,
now they endow this thing called
the Canada research chairs,
which is the highest chaired professorship
that the Canadian government can
bestow on a professor.
Now,
equity and diversity is essential
metric that is looked at.
So in the context where meritocracy
should beat the defining ethos of
everything, right? I mean when
you run the hundred meters dash,
there is no equity in diversity. Who
crosses the line? The furthest, right?
The size of my CV.
And how many people consume the
material in that CV are the metrics? No,
it's equity. Diversity. So I've
been a chaired professor, I hold it,
I held a university wide chair for 10
years and again I got this year in 2008
where my dose would have been much,
much less than what it is today. Sure.
I now applied for the next chair.
I lost it.
The person to whom I lost it.
Let me just do this is her CV.
This is my CV.
I don't obviate suddenly this case.
Perhaps it had something to do with the
fact that she's a woman. So your uh,
even though you're a
refugee and an immigrant and
technically look just nice and
bronze, you are Brown. I guess
Brown, you're from the Middle East.
I mean it's right. All of those
things get thrown out the window.
You don't play that
card. Exactly. Exactly.
When it comes to those particular
identity politics, calculus,
the one that matters right
now is that one, I mean,
or if you were indigenous or something
like that, but uh, being brown,
being escaping the capitation, the Lebanon
is not as important as observation.
Yeah. I think you're going to be
writing a little bit about this as well,
but what do you make about
what's going on right now?
There seems to be like a gender war
starting or something [inaudible] well,
just that there's this weird tension
suddenly between men and women.
I think that seems to be
bubbling up everywhere.
That obviously is somehow connected to
this new version of feminism. Ah, well,
I mean, listen, I've been,
I've been dealing with this even before
all the social justice warrior is just
the fact that I've been
trying to Darwin eyes, uh,
the behavioral sciences in general
and consumer behavior in particular,
that itself was heretical idea.
So that was thought of this excess
basically because men and women like
different products, it's just that
men and women have different, look,
there are many things that
make men and women similar.
There are many things that
make men and women different.
And the only framework that explains
the cataloging of similarities and
differences is evolutionary psychology.
And there is no other game in town. Right.
But the fact that you even recognize
that men and women might have evolved
sexual dimorphism, that itself is
heritable in much of the social sciences.
So even before the sort of cultural
wars that you hear about just in science
itself, uh, you know,
I'm an interesting guy in terms of my
academic background and that I really do
straddle the natural sciences
and the social sciences. Yeah.
So I could say the exact same sentence.
If it's heard by natural scientists,
they go, yeah, no kidding.
The exact same sentence heard by
the social sciences booboo Nazi.
Give me an example of that.
Well, just for example,
saying that there are evolved sex
differences, just that, right.
I mean the fact that of the 21st century,
a professor has to appear in front of the
Canadian Senate to say the things that
I had to say and then be
accused of being pro genocide.
What more do I need to say?
I mean that,
that captures the Zeitgeists
of Luna to see that exists.
What do you think has to
happen to turn this around?
Because on one hand it's like,
look,
all of these conversations that
so many of us are happening there,
they're growing. You know,
there's, there's, uh,
live events happening all over the
place that people are attending.
And so there is an awareness of this,
but I still sent were just the
frog in the pot right there.
That thing is just getting warmer and
warmer and we're looking around and we're,
we're realizing, oh, there's other frogs
in here. But they're looking at us going,
oh,
you're getting warm too.
So we'll go back to an earlier
point that we talked about. We said,
how do we get people to get engaged?
There's really, it's not rocket science.
You have to marginalize
the voices of lunacy.
And you do that by having the tsunami of
reason overtake the tsunami of Lunacy.
The problem is that a few highly committed
intellectual terrorists can hold the
rest of the people hostage. Right?
On nine 11, it only took 19 people.
It didn't take 19,000
of them take 19 million.
It took 19 people who were very committed
that morning to cause a level of the
structure that is unimaginable.
By the same token,
it doesn't take too many miscreants
and universities to cause damage,
but if everybody gets up and says,
look,
I'm indignant about these
constant injuries to truth,
I won't accept you saying the
things that you're saying.
Challenge your professor when he or she
says, bs challenged your Facebook friend.
If you get enough people to
marginalize the voices of lunacy,
then the very quickly the tide will,
will, will, will be overturned.
Do you think that the universities,
let's say 20 years from now we're
going to be completely different?
I mean the amount of access to information
and two great minds that you have on
youtube is incredible.
I mean,
you can learn about psychology
from Jordan Peterson.
You can learn about behavior from gads ad.
You can learn about a evolutionary
biology from Bret Weinstein.
I mean I could go on that.
People are learning in a new way now and
it almost for as much fun as I had in
college and as much as
I learned in college,
it's like at some level it's like
with this hysteria, if I was a parent,
why would I want to pay money
to have my kid reprogrammed?
If it's something that has nothing
to do with any of my beliefs,
I think universities
will eventually adapt,
but it will take much
longer than 20 years. So,
and I say this somewhat facetiously,
but it's actually a quite pretty
good description. You know,
we have meetings to set up
task forces to hold meetings,
to have a motion to have a task
force that we'll brainstorm, right?
That's the side whether we should
have more coffee in the mail room.
That's the pace at which the mail room,
the mail
box like Moscow, the exact, yeah. So, so,
so you can't have an institution that is
supposed to have great velocity and in
its ability to adjust to,
I mean we teach this in the business
school yet we don't apply it.
It takes us 50 years to adjust to
market conditions. So regrettably,
I think more and more people will
look for alternative, uh, sources of,
of information, as you said,
on Youtube and everywhere else.
So I got one for you that just popped
into my head that I wasn't planning on
asking you and I have no idea
if you've put any thought into.
But one of the things I've
been thinking about lately,
especially because of what's happened
here with Patriot and I want to figure out
how to move ahead with my business,
is that the numbers related to what's
happening online and on television seem
incredibly out of whack in that there
are millions and millions of people,
uh,
ingesting all of this online content
watching for extremely long times.
So the example I'll use is my chat,
we Shapiro in Peterson from two weeks
ago had, has over a million views.
The watch time is average
watch time is over 40 minutes,
which is unheard of on Youtube.
Um,
this is way more than NBC nightly
news gets, let's say on a,
on an average night or certainly more than
CNN gets out. CNN is a better example.
So you take Anderson Cooper,
eight o'clock whatever he's getting,
whatever numbers he's getting, that
brings in millions of dollars in revenue,
a two hour conversation that we do here.
I think it's made about 5,000
bucks or something like that.
What's the behavioral or marketing aspect
of this thing that needs to be flipped?
What?
What's causing the monetization of these
conversations is more lucrative and I
don't even mean this within the lens of
so that we, so that we make more money.
Yeah.
I don't even mean it that way.
I need it like something seems wrong with
me with the structures right now that
people are paying that old
school companies are paying
a ton of money for things
that have just existed forever that
nobody watches and nobody cares about.
Then there's this new thing
that everyone's watching
young people really care
about and yet it's getting pennies
on the dollar of the other thing.
What's the behavior pattern for the people
that are making that are probably of
all the levers.
So you're right that I hadn't thought
about it as I'm doing it on the fly.
And maybe the best way that I'll describe
it as by telling a another story and
what's going to be common about
my story and what your ask is.
The fact that most people,
once they are anchored in a particular
way of behavior, it's very difficult.
The inertia is very difficult to shift.
So I was invited to speak at Stanford
University business school. I mean,
it doesn't get more prestigious
than this. Okay. Uh,
the gentleman who took me out to dinner,
uh,
the night before my talk at Stanford
Business School is a pretty well known
consumer psychologist who is now one of
the editors of one of the major journals.
So he's a serious academic and
at one point he says, you know,
I didn't know you were such a celebrity
and you appear on Joe Rogan and all.
I thought, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I tried to do it all. He said,
and so he looked, he says,
yeah, well, you know, at Stanford
we don't really promote, uh,
you know, this kind of stuff.
I said, what'd you mean?
And he picked sort of the wrong
guy to act this way. He goes, well,
you know,
we don't do research so that we can be
half sexy findings that we can repeat on
Joe Rogan that we can, you know,
discuss on Joe Rogan. I said, well,
I'm not suggesting that you either do
scientific research or appear on Joe
Rogan. I'm saying, do scientific
research and appear on Joe Rogan.
Surely you as a professor of marketing,
you would appreciate the
fact that appearing on Joe
Rogan and having 10 million
people consume your ideas might be as
valuable as a paper that you published in
a scientific journal that's read.
This is maybe why I'm not, uh, the,
I don't get invited in some of
these parties that's read by you,
the editor to reviewers and
your mom. Yeah, that didn't,
that didn't sit too well. I've had
the rest of the dinner. I mean,
it was a bitsa frosty, but, but,
but he didn't pay for the state.
But you know, he didn't, he did that.
He was hospitable in that, that says,
but that speaks to the point
that you're at, which is, uh,
even a place like
Stanford Business School,
which is supposed to have
the brightest minds possible,
is resistant to change.
I mean, Joel, well,
you'd think that it would understand as
a business school that having your ideas
heard on a platform that is 10 million
people. Yeah. Rogan is, uh, you know,
it's insane how huge is that.
Might have something to do with
that might be good for business.
Perhaps selling a book or sharing.
Exactly. Exactly. But I think so now,
not to get too psychoanalytical,
but I will, uh, look,
it's an ego defensive strategy,
right? So I'm speaking as him now,
I have mastered the set of skills that
I need to succeed in publishing papers,
in peer review journals.
I don't think I could appear in front
of Joe Rogan and 10 million people.
Therefore I will
denigrate those who do it.
So it's a classic Eagle
Defensive Strategy.
Whereas the truly intellectually
secure person would say, no.
I am going to find all of the possible
mediums where I can share my ideas.
Academics are in the business of creating
mimetic knowledge and spreading it,
right? So I create the knowledge
in my scientific research,
but if they Ruben asked me to come on
a show, I would be a lunatic to think,
to turn it down. Why would I turn
it down? I want to promote my ideas.
Is that the fun part of
what's going on right now?
That everything is kind of upside down?
So while it does seem scary,
it's also like,
Oh,
if you have your head on right and you're
and you're willing to suck up your ego
a little bit and maybe do some things
that maybe you wouldn't have done 10 years
ago, it's like, wow, there's a, there's a
ton of opportunity. It's unbelievably fun.
I wake up every day like
a kid in a candy store.
I'm excited by all of the endless
possibilities that await me and I love,
I love doing very,
very hardcore scientific research.
I love appearing on Ruben or Rogan.
I love speaking in front
of students in class.
Anything that allows me to spread
ideas I'm going to sign up for.
And I only wish I could convince a lot
of my academic colleagues who remain
quite high Falutin uh,
in their ivory towers to join.
And I think they will eventually. Yeah.
Well that's actually a perfect segue.
Can you mention a couple of the other
academics that you've had on your yes to
channel lately? Uh, that
are in some hot water.
They dare speak the truth. Yes. Thank
you. I'm going to be plugging them now.
Maybe people will listen. So, so I had,
so I don't know if you know why you do
know that I'm quite satirical and quite
sarcastic. So, and one of the your
video hiding under the bed. Oh,
exactly what you're
going to talk about her.
So now I have a series where I hide
under the table because I'm so afraid.
So the last installment of that
series was because I was very,
very afraid because a white supremacist
and quotes Rachel Fulton Brown,
who is a professor of medieval
history at University of Chicago.
What's coming on my show and you know,
as a brown Middle Eastern person,
I was very afraid of her white supremacy.
Now what is it that caused her to receive
the appellation of white supremacy?
It's that she wrote a very, very short
blog posts where she said, you know,
three hails to white men. A lot of
the freedoms that we have in the West,
a lot of the,
the,
the feminist virtues have been pushed
and supported and defended by white men.
So maybe they deserve some credit. My God,
what a Nazi. I mean, it's, it's almost,
she's almost indistinguishable from
Hemler himself. So that's one case.
How many people came to her
defense? Very few. Okay.
The second one is a gentleman high,
just had last week on,
his name is Alessandro's through Mia.
He is an Italian physicist
at the University of Pisa
who is also associated with
the uh,
uh,
research center called Cern Crn,
which is an acronym in,
in Geneva where they're doing the call.
[inaudible] exactly.
So he's a very polite and [inaudible]
extent of my scientific knowledge are out
there going to blow up the university.
They going to grow up the university.
Exactly.
And so he was invited to speak at a
gender and theoretical physics or some,
some, some identity politics,
you know, event, uh, you know,
basically to support the narrative that
women are deeply discriminated against
in physics.
And so rather than buy into the narrative,
what he decided to do is actually
present biblio metric data. Do you,
do you know what that is?
Help me out here.
Maybe they'll metric data
is if you'd like. It's the
scientific study of science.
For example, if you want to study
which fields sites, which other fields,
you could look at citation patterns.
So it's like building networks,
but it's scientific networks.
So it's you, you're quantifying,
you're taking a snapshot of science
itself. Is that science, science?
It's the science of science. It's,
and it's called bibliometrics.
Probably the most famous journal within
that jar is called psychometrics.
And I've published a few papers in
that journal. So what he did is he, he,
he did a book,
the metric analysis.
So let me give you an example of that so
that we can give you a concrete thing.
So if you have men and women applying
for a particular job in physics,
what is the average number of citations?
So citations for your viewers
who don't know if for example,
I've published 50 scientific papers and
you've published 50 scientific papers,
your 50 papers might've
been site at 10,000 times.
My 50 papers might've
been cited 2000 times,
even though we've both
published the same amount.
Your papers have been
cited a lot more than mine.
You're more influential in that sense.
So it's one measure of
scientific prominence.
And so what he did is he
looked at four specific jobs.
What is the average number of citations
that women candidates who got the job
had versus men? And he found that
men have a lot more citations,
right? Uh, well that's
just data right? Big.
Now because he presented data that
seemed to contradict the narrative.
And he did. One other thing that
some would argue as a football,
I'm not sure how much of a football it is,
he actually compared his citation record
to two other women and named them.
But that data is publicly available
that people thought of it as Gauche.
But originally when sir, that
might've been Gauche or in poor taste,
but that doesn't deny this the science.
Exactly.
So these complete idiots
particles for justice,
that what are the of noxious steam
particles for justice? Right.
That's actually the name.
So which is a constellation of
castrates at scientists. Yeah.
About 1600 of them.
So if I didn't have enough enemies,
now I have 6,100 new enemies. Uh, give
me five more minutes. Okay, let's,
let's start to exactly. Uh, they,
they came up with a, a letter,
an open letter. Uh, you
know, saying how bad he is.
We do not support any
physicist who do humanize a,
someone based on their religion, their
ethnicity, their gender orientation,
their race. He did no such thing.
He, he didn't mention race,
he didn't mention gender orientation,
he didn't mention ethnicity or religion,
but somehow he's now in Nazi on all
fronts simply because he shared with be a
metric data. Well, nobody would touch
the sky. Guess who, who would touch him,
this guy.
And for better or worse,
I've become the central
repository of every academic,
every student, every administrator,
every staff who is aggrieved,
we'll end up writing. To me, and frankly,
it's on the one hand is very exciting
because you feel like you're helping.
On the other hand,
it's,
it's takes a tremendous emotional toll
on you because you have to go about your
business being a professor,
writing your grants and writing your
papers and supervising your doctoral
students. But every day
you're overcome by 10 stories,
each of which upsets you,
but you can't address each one.
So it takes a burden on you.
Well,
not that you want to be more
overwhelmed than you are,
but I could probably send you five easily,
probably four or 500 stories exactly.
Like,
there's people who want to come on my
show and I obviously I've had some of
these people as they've sort
of bubbled up, you know,
I've had more of the high profile ones,
like a James Damore let's say,
or what happened at Bret Weinstein. But,
but Lindsay, a shepherd from Canada,
you know, we helped put her on
the map I think. But the amount,
I get these stories from
everybody I'm talking about,
I'm getting them from
elementary school teachers.
I'm getting them from obviously from
professors, but I'm getting them from,
from people that have nothing to do with
academia. I'm getting them from, uh,
you know, people that are in engineering
and all sorts of other things.
So it's just endless. But what, okay, what
do you think these, uh, what were they?
Equality and equity and diversity. Oh, I,
particles for justice particles or does
he, so let's, let's try to steal a man.
Their argument.
What do you think they actually want?
Do they actually want that?
Physics departments should have
the exact breakdown of females.
So let's say females are like 52% of
males are 48. Something like that.
Absolutely.
Think that actually the best way to
move physics forward in the future is to
have 52% females, 48%
males. Regardless of that,
men and women like different things and
that studies are something differently
and all the things they truly believe
that let's all give the devil his due here
like,
or they don't believe it.
And the deep recesses of their minds
when they're about to go to bed and the
privacy of their thoughts,
but to the public,
they certainly must demonstrate
that they do believe it.
So whether they truly believe
it or not is up for debate,
but there certainly signaling
that they believe, okay,
so let's take that section of them and I,
that's probably a huge amount of them.
Right? That's just the hot, that's
just sort of the week hostage is. Yeah,
I'd say so let's move those people out.
Now let's take the true believers in this.
You think they just,
they truly believe, even though they are
educated, these are, these are physicists.
Yes.
They believe that that would produce,
or are they putting physics
aside for the purposes of equity?
You know what I mean? Well, it's
funny because I actually do,
what do they think is more important?
Equity or physics I guess is my question.
Uh, which speaks to another point that
I talk about in my forthcoming book,
which is,
you know,
there are often times mission statements
that don't go hand in hand. If you,
if you do more of one,
you have to give up on the
other universities exist
for the pursuit of truth.
If in the pursuit of truth,
feelings are hurt. So be it.
This is exactly when Sam Harris on his
podcast, when I appeared a few years ago,
we don't, one of the first
things that he led with was, uh,
in your scientific word,
God,
is there anything that you
consider to be forbidden knowledge?
And my answer was an unequivocal no.
If you are an adherent truthfully and
honestly through the scientific method,
then it's not my job as a scientist to
worry about how that knowledge might be
misused because then it truly
is a slippery slope. Right?
We shouldn't have done physics research
because, you know, Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
right? Uh, that's by the way,
what caused one of the reasons that
cause the abdication of biology from the
study of human behavior.
What's precisely because some social
scientists thought that by biology
[inaudible] human nature that
could be misused, like by,
by you, the Eugenesis, by the Nazis,
by British class elitists,
and therefore let's create a new edifice
that's completely removed from reality.
But where biology is no longer relevant.
So what these physicists are doing is
they've been parasitized by the Arctic
ideas. Physicists could be just as Moronic
as anybody else. As a matter of fact,
I've met quite a few physicists short
of whatever they know and physics. Uh,
they're fully lobotomized. So it's not
as though being in physics affords you a,
you know, greater knowledge
and in greater life. Right?
I guess that's just depressing at
some level. There's nothing but isn't.
The other inherent problem with that.
If you're afraid to go where science
we'll lead you because of whatever the
politically correct notion of the day
is that you're going to leave scientists
to allow us, you're gonna leave science
to a lot of bad people. Absolutely.
I mean that's, that's exactly why
I get so frustrated, right? I mean,
I've had reviewers, if I,
and I've kept the reviews, I
send the paper to a journal.
If I show you some of the reviews
I get back, you would think,
although this has god being satirical,
right,
but why is he studying sex differences?
Does he not know the danger of, I mean,
do I really in the 21st century have to
explain to you that there is inherent
value in studying evolved sex differences.
The fact that you get a reaction of
indignation and discuss and you call
yourself a scientist is like being in
the 13th century. It's breathtaking.
But that's because they believe they
place on sort of the hierarchy of ideals
they plays, uh, hurt feelings or the, the,
the refusal to have hurt feelings
above truth. Do you think all of this,
like almost everything we're talking
about here and sort of everything that
we're all fighting? Yes. All the time.
Simply like if we were to just boil
it down to, it's like, you know,
let's go to first
principles sort of thing.
That it's just because of an abdication
of personal responsibility that people
are just sort of afraid of their shadow.
They're just afraid that it's a little
bit of a scary idea to just get up every
morning and go, I gotta do a little
better today. It's definitely,
there's a bit of that, but I think
that what unites a lot of these,
what in the book I call idea pathogens,
right?
The book is about parasitic ideas that
infest our brains causing us to behave
maladaptively a lot of these ideas are
ultimately abdication of reality because
they make me feel good in some way.
So for example,
the Tabula Rasa premise that
the empty empty mind premise,
do you know what I'm talking about?
This is basically idea that we are born
empty minds and it's only socialization,
sort of the blank slate. The black slate.
Exactly. So the, the fancy tournaments,
Tabula Rasa. Okay. In Latin, the
empty slate. Gotcha. Okay. Well,
I know we were doing the show in English.
I could break it up for you in Arabic
and Hebrew and French. Uh, but anyways,
but hey, by the way, Obama says Pakistan
in this way. So he's the worldly guy.
Right, right, right, right. But, uh,
but the Tabula Rasa premise really
comes from a very hopeful place. Why?
Because it says that we are all
born with equal potentiality.
Had I simply been hugged
better by my mother?
I too could have been Michael Jordan,
but there was something, right?
There was something in my environmental
trajectory that caused it,
that that realization happen
for Michael Jordan. But not me.
But there was nothing inherent
at the start at t equals zero.
That would have led Michael Jordan to
have greater likelihood of becoming the
NBA started. He would have become rather
than me at five foot six and a half.
Right. Well that's helpful.
I'd like to believe that.
I'd like to believe that we are
all born with zero biological,
no innate differences in intelligence,
for example.
Know that makes me feel where it
would sort of be a beautiful thing.
It's a thing, right? Work.
So I think a lot of these parasitic
ideas all stem from a very noble place.
It stems from a place where you're trying
to sanitize the ugliness of reality.
So for example, to link it back
to marketing, the dove campaign,
that's probably the most
successful campaign of their
czar is one that basically
says, look, we're all equally beautiful.
There is no beauty is a social
construct. Well, if I'm a woman,
do I want to hear that message or do I
want to hear God sad telling me that?
No,
across all cultures,
facially symmetric people are judged
as a more beautiful than facially
asymmetric, right? It just is.
If my nose was all the way this
way and I had one eye over here,
I wouldn't be as attractive. But if that
were true, that would smell a fatalism.
That means I can't, I'm doing to that
asymmetry. But if you tell me no,
don't worry about it.
In the right context,
people will judge your sagging
breasts, your, your, uh, uh,
you've wrinkled face. You're asymmetry
to be as beautiful. And look,
there's the movement, fat
acceptance, for example, factory
acceptance. Sorry. No, no,
go ahead. This is just a doozy of one,
because now you have people that are,
that are in it is not healthy to be fat.
It's not a controversial statement.
Have we noticed that?
I've lost 30 pounds if I'm not
mistaken. Very good. Very good. Well,
thank you for notice.
Yes, no, but seriously,
since this will work well for you in
your career and in large life at law,
but fat acceptance basically says,
look,
it's a conspiracy from the
medical establishment to
argue that being overweight
is a bad thing. And so I actually troll
my physician. I joined, said, hey,
don't you dare tell me that I need
to lose weight. As a matter of,
at one point I had gone to see him and I
actually mentioned this in the book and
he pulls out,
he doesn't bring up my cholesterol scores.
He pulls out a couple of tweets of mine.
I'm guessing he follows me,
doesn't realize that I'm being
sarcastic as I write, you know, my, my,
my,
my physician is a complete fattest.
He said that I needed to lose weight.
Doesn't even know that, uh, you know,
this is a social construct. I'm trans
gravity, blah, blah, whatever. Yeah.
My usual got stuff.
And then he points to them.
Actually my wife was in
the room with me and,
and he pointed them and basically he's
questioning my emotional state and my
sanity, so I won't say
his name. I go, doc,
I was being sarcastic.
That's hilarious.
So physicians can be plugged surprised
by an inability to think and detect
sarcasm. Yeah. But, but so I think there
is, the root of that though is again,
it's personal responsibility,
right? Because isn't it?
It's very easy to be like,
all right, well I'm
fat or whatever. Right.
And I have no reason to.
It's not about me to get myself in order.
It's not about any of that. So that,
it just strikes me that almost
every problem that we're
seeing in society, right,
as his disease is due to the
ultimate abdication of people,
of just that it's their life.
They seem right.
Forgot that it's their life or something.
By the way though,
the fact that something is determined
by some evolutionary mechanism doesn't
mean that it is biologically
deterministic. I had an, uh,
of course I won't mention the
name of the person I had. Yeah,
I received probably be like,
you do a million emails of people asking
me for advice and I unfortunately I
can't answer everybody, but once in
a while someone forward them to you.
There you go. That's why I received so
many. And so one gentleman wrote to me,
it was a guy of a certain age in his late
twenties saying basically that he had
never had sex and he feels very distraught
by it then is there any hope for me,
Dr Saad, blah, blah, blah. And you know,
I didn't know exactly what to answer,
but I said, look, the reality is that uh,
many of the attributes that women look
for in men are actually attributes that
we could improve on. So for
example, your economic status,
your social status, your educational
level, your confidence level,
those are not determining what is,
what is determined is the fact that
women are attracted to those traits.
But you could score here on
them now and through hard work,
through personal responsibility, you
could move here. Now my facial symmetry,
I can't change. And so in that sense,
if I'm a bit, this is Los Angeles,
this is the [inaudible] gastric
surgery. True. Yeah, you're right. But,
but there are many attributes.
Even though we know the evolutionary
roots of those attributes,
that doesn't mean that we are doing that
simply actually informs us about those
things that if we take personal
responsibility we could improve on. Uh,
I wanted to talk to you about,
uh, I asked you right before,
cause I didn't want to screw it up.
The indeed indigenization
indigenization at the university.
The university's like,
since I've out again,
I get one word that I
can't quite know. Yeah. Uh,
so one of the things that's happening
kind of as you know, there's,
there's been a lot of,
of historical friction between
the Canadian government and the,
the native people,
the indigenous people.
And so now we've gone on hyper drive
where everything is getting indigenized.
So for example, when you start
any ceremony at the university,
you have to self flagellate. I'm evil. Uh,
we are standing on stolen line and so on,
which that itself I find
quite grotesque because, uh,
not to imply that there haven't been
historical grievances that should be
addressed that and so on.
But here are students who have nothing
to do with those historical grievances.
This is their moment to shine.
This is their moment to be celebrated.
We start off by saying, you're a bad,
you're on stolen land. Admit that. Right?
So that's one example. But that
that's okay. Symbolic fine,
but it's not just symbolic,
right?
Because doesn't that just leak into
everything else? You're like, fair enough.
You're absolutely right. So here's what
bothers me more as someone who is a dog,
good defender of truth.
We now have what's called
indigenous way of knowing. Okay,
so here's,
here's the,
here's where it's appropriate to talk
about indigenous knowledge versus
inappropriate.
Indigenous people have lived in certain
environments that makes them more privy
to the local knowledge of the
flora of the fauna, right?
It's content specific knowledge.
If you've lived in a particular
region for 10,000 years,
you might have some statistical
regularities that you've
noticed as part of your
cultural transmission that the guy who's
sitting at Harvard may not have been
exposed to. You have a lot of transmitted
data. Yeah. You except this is true.
I accept this as true
and we should turn to,
to the indigenous folks for their
locally specified knowledge.
On the other hand, if
you say no, but you know,
I could look at the shadow of my ancestor,
whatever,
some Booga Booga stuff.
Uh,
because that's an alternate way of also
in a way it's not just the white man's
sexist, racist colonial science
that we should abide by. No.
The original extremely good looking
Lebanese Jew way of knowing there is no
indigenous way of knowing.
There is just the scientific method.
So once you try to argue that
there are multiple ways of knowing
epistemologically you're entering into
bs Lon and I won't put up with it.
Can you explain to me away
that they would say that?
How would they make the
counter argument to that?
What would they be talking about?
Well,
what would be an indigenous
way of knowing not,
I'm not talking about the legitimate part,
when not everything is material science.
Not Everything is materialism.
Not everything can be captured by
conducting an experiment using white man's
science. Hashtag science must fall, right?
You have to decolonize your mind, man.
You have to accept there are,
you know,
central African Way of knowing
where you understand the rain to be,
that God is crying. You have
to understand saying, yeah,
so you have to incorporate people's
mythologies and folklores into ways of
knowing.
Shamanism is a way of knowing that is
very different in terms of how you cure
cancer. That has nothing to do
with western science. It's BS.
There is only one way of knowing and
it's called the scientific method.
But by the way, people
who do, for example, touch
therapy, touch therapy is, uh,
I have an energy state and my,
and I could cure your pancreatic
cancer simply by hovering right now.
When you actually do a study to check
the efficacy, it obviously fails.
What do you think they rebuffed?
Well by putting us through
the vulgar tests of science.
It that in that itself the magic,
there you go.
So there is no indigenous way of knowing.
There is very valuable indigenous
knowledge that should be maintained,
preserved and shared.
But there is no different epis thermology
there is no way to get at the truth
other than the scientific method.
It's the only game in town.
How is this leaking into
academia? I mean, is this now,
is this a discipline that's
being taught or it's just,
or it's just sort of the lower layer of
it? It's everywhere. It's that you, you,
you in curricular and gets
imported, imported. Uh, the,
I think it was the Environment Minister
of Quebec who questioned when talking
about some environmental policy.
He basically said something similar to
what I'm saying here where he's saying
there is only the scientific
method. He was clobbered. No,
there isn't just a scientific matter.
What kind of racist pig are you?
Is there something unique or something
bizarre about what's happening in Canada
right now that so many of the fighters
right now that the world is looking at
are coming from Canada? I
mean, look, there's, there's
something that your water,
yeah, well Peterson obviously I think
is the, is the pinnacle of this. Um,
but you, but Lindsay Shepherd, I, there's
a series of other people, Janice Fandango.
Janice, you may go ahead and here who's
just off the charts phenomenal. Uh,
that there's something happening in
Canada perhaps that you guys had it pretty
good and stayed at a world
affairs enough or something.
But now the Internet has like made us
all feel the same, right? Or I don't,
I don't think there's anything, I think
it's just a statistical anomaly that, uh,
a few of the forefront people
happen to be from Canada.
I don't think there's any, it may be, it's
this completely, I'm sorry, I'm not sure,
but maybe the fact that we are actually
getting parasitized by some of these
idiotic ideas so much more quickly.
I think so.
Maybe that's it because I think there's
some connection to Trudeau so slick and
says all the right things, but everyone
knows he's not doing the right things.
And you know, when we were in western
Canada, there was a lot of people,
almost all the questions
when we do these Q and A's,
we're about what's going on with,
uh,
the oil pipeline and all that
and taxes and all these things.
But he looks good anywhere. It's nice
on us and he can dance. That's right.
And so people just think it's good.
So maybe it's something like,
like Canadians I think generally
are a little more, it's odd.
It correct me if I'm wrong on this.
My gut feeling about Canadians is you
guys are a little more inherently live and
let live say libertarian,
except you have a government that gives
you your dues and a whole bunch of other
things. So there's a weird dichotomy
there. I mean, maybe I'll go,
I can tell you that in Quebec,
uh,
we're one of the last functioning deeply
communist places in the world. Uh,
I say that somewhat facetiously, but
not quite facetiously. We really,
that one of the reasons why I've always
wanted to move to the United States is
because this socialist ethos is really
great for people who don't do much.
And it really punishes those
who are, uh, producers. Yeah.
And so you're constantly getting the
government who comes at you and says, Hey,
everything you do 50 50 right.
So it's not enough that I,
my salary is taxed at a
level that is unimaginable.
That would make most of the people
viewing the show have heart attacks.
Is that anything that I try to
do beyond that to, to make a bet,
if I go give a talk, if I write
a book, if I'm on Patriot,
the government says whatever you do
forevermore, if it's world income,
if it's on Mars, we're 50 50
partners, as a matter of fact,
ends up being much more than 50 50 because
your income is about 50% but then the
50% that's left to you,
they tax you 15% on what you spend.
So the amount that I'm left with, I mean,
so how could it be that someone who,
it's not that I'm very rich,
it's not that I make you,
but if you look at sort of that
I probably am in the top 5%.
I'm left with very little at the
end of the year because you know,
we are a gentle sweet society where
you have free health care. Well,
it's free health care other than the
fact that I pay 50% of my income for it.
So if you exclude the 50% that I pay
for it, it's free. So for example,
[inaudible] that upsets people when you
tell them that something is that's free
is actually paid for,
that really upsets people because they
live in that utopia where the blank slate
premise is the, uh, the theory
that ego, you know, they're idiots.
You got one more good one for me
before we sign off. We, I mean,
we could do this forever and I know we're,
unfortunately, I got some more stuff.
I gotta do that. Anything else
that I can tell you? Uh, well my,
my book will be out next year.
I am supposed to deliver it in October.
Um,
feverously working on it.
There was a bit of a snag it last year
where I wasn't able to work on it as much.
Now I'm back full throttle.
I have about half of the book written
and somewhat disorganized fashion.
Our books are going to come out at about
the same time. I know that's not good.
That's bad news for you because of
course I'm going to overshadow you.
I was about to say that we
could tour together. Nope. Nope.
Diplomatic. I'm Middle Eastern. I
have to learn from you. Yeah. See,
I try to impart a little wisdom
at the end. Thank you sir.
It's been a pleasure as always, my friend
where were, okay, so Patriot obviously,
but where else can people support? So
this is the thing that everyone thought.
So I just signed up on
subscribed star. Uh, I also,
they could follow me. I have a
youtube channel. The sad truth act,
Gad side is my Twitter handle. I've got up
on the frame. Yeah. That was just going,
how can they support all support
me for support, pow, subscribed,
star and Patrion. Yeah. I don't
really don't end the show with the,
with the pimping out of that nature,
but I just think people are trying
to figure it out now. They want it.
They want to support good ideas in strange
and I should say I'm everyday that I
see your success. You know, there's
an old expression that says, uh,
whenever I see my friends succeed,
something in me dies,
which is the ugly emotion of envy.
I feel the opposite for you.
And I truly mean that every
as I see you flourish, I say,
I knew this guy when he was a fetus and
I love that you are this big Herculean
guy now. Good for you buddy. Can wish.
I love that you're doing
it right alongside me. So
thank you. Are, there you go.
All right, well say more nice things
to each other off camera. Um, so yes.
So just very quickly,
uh,
I'm trying to figure out what to
do with the Patriot and situation.
If you are not happy with
what they're doing there.
And I'm still trying to get more
information on everything. Uh,
you can go to Dave rubin.com/donate if
you'd like to do that. And, uh, all right,
this is,
this is my last taping in the studio
for 2018 and it was a completely bananas
here. I did about a hundred stops on
the road, uh, got back into stand up.
I think we did some good stuff here. We
do have shows coming out, uh, on Monday.
I think we have a eamomm Tahiti and then,
uh,
which we take just a couple of days ago.
It's really wild, a great interview. Uh,
and then we've got rabbi
David Wolpe and Bishop Barron.
I think that's on Wednesday,
if I'm not mistaken.
We've got a clip show at the end of
the year and a couple of other things.
Thank you for watching.
And good.